Interviewer: I'm here with Marcos.
What is this an experiment we're doing?
I was like hey instead
of having pictures on our
website, maybe we should
have videos of people.
Marcos: Nice. Nice.
Interviewer: So, what do you do here?
Marcos: I'm a designer
here at the Khan Academy.
That actually goes two different ways.
One, I'm kind of doing
my software design, and
that's kind of touching on the
exercise framework that we have.
Right now I've been focused
a lot on trying to make
more interactive exercises
easier to develop.
There's a framework that
I'm building for that
I'm [open sourcing] at the same time.
Interviewer: What do you mean
by more interactive exercise?
Marcos: Right now a lot of
our exercises present to you
with a question. It's like, what
is the sum of blah blah blah?
Or, complete the square.
It ask you this very simple
one step computation. A lot
of stuff that I'm looking at
is how do you make exercises
that let you follow
a larger kind of narrative
of problem solving.
In that case it would be
like, let's say you are
this tall here, and your
shadow is this feet long.
Your friend is over, maybe,
35 nautical miles away, and
his shadow is this long.
Giving that what do you
expect the circumference
of the earth to be?
Interviewer: Oh yeah.
Marcos: You're recreating like
the greatest ... doing all the
scientific discoveries.
Their not very hard if
you know the basic concepts in there.
You just need someone to
guide you along the way.
A lot of what I've been
thinking about is developing
a framework and actually
developing a framework
not just thinking about it.
Interviewer: Right. Right.
Marcos: For making that happen.
Interviewer: You'r background
is pretty interesting.
You started off at MIT. CS major?
Marcos: Math with CS.
Interviewer: Math with CS.
Marcos: People call it diet 6.
Interviewer: Diet 6. 6 is
of course computer science.
Marcos: 6 is computer science.
Interviewer: It's kind of the math
... computer science really is math.
Then you decided that that was not enough.
Marcos: I think I was pleasantly surprised
with how that had gone.
What I was really focused
on at the time was the
[unintelligible] in the context
of making text books. Text
books [unintelligible]
dining out or whatever. I
still believe. I want to
make a really good text book.
Interviewer: We got text books
here and some science books.
Marcos: I actually ended
up doing after teaching
web design for about a year
and a half was applying
to design school. The whole
purpose behind that was
to make a really awesome text book.
Interviewer: I didn't
realize this. This didn't
even come out in the
interview. You wanted to
re-event text books?
Marcos: Yeah. Yeah. I
wanted to actually make
the coolest text book.
Like after being in design
school making handmade books for example.
Like 4 x 6 little book
would be really sweet.
I was like really excited
and jazzed about this.
Then as I started in
2007 to 2009, it was you
have the iPad, iPhone,
all these technological
advances just happen
while I'm in grad school.
I will have to rethink this a little.
I got this design degree.
Interviewer: From [Risty].
Marcos: From [Risty].
Interviewer: That's a serious
design school. That's around there.
Marcos: I had did my
grad program in design.
I got a lot of the basics.
I learned all of the
fundamentals hypography, design, layout.
I got really attuned to
that, and then focused
my energies again thinking
about how do I create
reusable design systems. I
ended up being my thesis was ...
Interviewer: How many
CS majors were there?
Marcos: Actually, when I
left there was 1 and a half.
Interviewer: 1 and a half. (laughing)
Marcos: It's an up and coming thing.
Interviewer: Yeah. I think
that's a good combination.
In fact, I think, probably,
design should be a critical
part of more engineers.
Marcos: Yeah. Exactly.
What I noticed, at least,
there was a lot of similarity.
The Christopher Alexander design
patterns thinking. That
system thinking, actually,
is massive in graphic design.
Interviewer: Yeah.
Marcos: It was also huge
in the design pattern
movement in [Seasia]. There's
a lot of happy medium there.
Interviewer: Why did
you decide to come here?
How did you even find out
about what were doing?
Marcos: I saw a lattice
multiplication video.
I was like this is
ridiculous. I was watching ...
Interviewer: In a good or bad way?
Marcos: At first I saw
it and I was like I have
never heard of lattice multiplication.
I saw this massive list
of links. Somebody had
a link to it. I was a
little skeptical. For some
reason I finished watching
the video, and I'm
like well that's interesting.
Interviewer: This was one of our videos.
Marcos: This was one of your videos.
Interviewer: It was a good ridiculous.
Marcos: Yeah. It was a good ridiculous.
First, I was incredibly
skeptical. I was just like
no, no, no. I done my little
concentration education
at secondary school, and
I was like I don't know.
You find yourself actually
finishing the video,
and you're like oh.
There's something here.
There's actually something
there. I didn't actually
see you guys again for a year and a half.
I was working at CMU and doing
my own thing at that time.
Interviewer: What was your own thing?
Marcos: I was doing freelance
work at the same time.
I was also working with the HCI Institute.
Interviewer: CMI is Carnegie Mellon.
Marcos: Yeah. Carnegie Mellon.
Human-Computer Interaction Institute.
Interviewer: Okay.
Marcos: With Laura Dabbish and
Rob Kraut an amazing group.
Their doing a really
interesting work with team
team based dynamics online.
Interviewer: What were you doing?
Marcos: I was actually staff designer, and
then doing some CS work from the side.
It's like doing a lot of
re-factoring with code based
and making sure that
we could re-producively
preform these experiments
on these couple thousand
Facebook users every week.
Interviewer: Okay.
Marcos: We were running
these massive experiments
until I learned, even though
I wasn't doing the straight up
experience design, I kind
of osmosed a lot of that
stuff while I was there.
Interviewer: I interrupted your story.
How did you find out
about what we're doing?
Marcos: I started seeing
... I think Ben came ...
Interviewer: We have 9 Ben's. (laughing)
Marcos: 9 Ben's. So, Ben
Kamens did a prety good
job posting out [unintelligible]
every once in a while.
Then, I was like man this
is totally changed from the
time I saw it. The first time,
I think, it had all ready
gone through that one design
aeration. It was pretty interesting.
Then I saw you guys were
actually posting for jobs.
I was like this is
perfect. What could be more
perfect than this? I just
threw my hat in the ring.
The rest is history. (laughing)
Interviewer: The rest
is history. (laughing)
Hopefully for the future
too. What we're hoping to do
here? Has it been surprising?
Has it been just as you expected?
Marcos: I think, actually,
when I first got here,
I think I even wrote that in my cover.
I don't know what I
will do when I get here,
but I'm really excited to do stuff here.
I had no idea that I'd be
working on interactive exercises.
I think that a good glimmer in my eye.
I though straight out of design school.
Straight out like a year and
a half out of design school.
I thought I would probably
be doing business cards,
logos, kind of stupid stuff.
Interviewer: Really. You were
capable of more than business cards.
Marcos: Of course. I'm capable.
Interviewer: That's where my
design skills were. (laughing)
Marcos: In my mind I
kind of expected to spend
a couple of months doing that.
I ended up just diving on in.
Thinking about new features.
Thinking about ways to make the
site more friendly, and
overall, it was a huge
mind-shifting, like the
terminal of like impacting scale
and the ability to do something
really cool in education.
It was like we did this
thing with David, one of
our awesome interns, and
it was how can we make
this [sweep] more fun.
We play with this very
simple visual forms and
like what happens when
you loose [street] bar.
What does that feel like?
A lot of these are very
designish things that
we're probing, but we
ended up coming up with
a very ... and he actually
deserves most of the
credit. He came up with
a very stunning model
for making that a more
interesting and more
appropriate way of engaging
and measuring our proficiency.
Interviewer: Deep design
questions got to measure.
Marcos: Does it feel better
to drop down to something
like to drop down to arbitrary
amount and start over again?
Does it feel better to
drop to a percentage
which represents our actual belief, and
how far you're doing? Which of these ...
Interviewer: How doing means you
actually belief in how your doing.
Marcos: Exactly. A lot
of that your questions of
would it feel better as
your gaining proficiency?
You have a moving indicator.
Something that kind of
moves along and animates. It was born out
of these playful ideas.
It actually ended up
evolving into something that
was very more metro rigorous.
Then like back and forths
that we were having
initially when we sketching it out.
Interviewer: Where do you hope this goes?
Marcos: I think, recently,
I've been spending
a lot of time thinking about
the interactive exercises,
and I actually feel like
I'm going closer to my
original idea for this text book.
I mean it sounds kind of
silly, but it feels like
what I'm doing and the
work that I'm working on
gets me closer to designing
these portable text books.
Which I mean not portable,
because we have phones
iPad's, and whatnot, but
things that are engaging
that are light weight, and that'll let you
dive in at any level. At your own risk.
Interviewer: Do things that
text books couldn't do?
Marcos: I think text books
are capable of a lot.
I'll be honest. Maybe
we disagree. (laughing)
Interviewer: (laughing) No. No.
Marcos: I firmly in the
power of the text book.
I think for the things
that ... for the reactive
exercises we can pull
off and for the ability
to ask questions that are experimentally.
You can place a little
experimental test bed
in one of these exercises,
and I think that's powerful.
I think it's huge right,
being able to see a whole.
I got the answer. What
happens if I have done this.
Seeing that there's an
exercise that is able to
adapt to that way of
thinking. I think that's huge.
Interviewer: Right. That
would have been hard
with a traditional text book.
Marcos: Yeah. You end up having
to build this scalpelling,
basically in paper, which
again totally fine. Right.
It's the time you can loose
being unable to explore
and play with tweaking values.
I think that's awesome.
Interviewer: Very cool.